how did you learn how to write these
scripts I'm talking about like movie to
write a movie you got to sort of know
how to write a movie how do you learn
how to do all of that I just did what
everybody does I read you know like the
how to write a screenplay book by uh
what's that guy Sid field right that's
the book and you read that a how-to book
you didn't go to college to learn how to
write scriptures no I said I studied
playwriting in college you did so you
were like an English major yeah I was a
drama major so then you start to begin
developing a writing skill yeah and you
go and you join Second City which is a
ballsy move we always you comfortable
taking the stage when you first went to
Second City it was uh you know it's
scary but compared to like I'm I'm so
amazed by people who do stand up because
you do stand up you're out there by
yourself and people can literally like
whip [ __ ] at you yes and throw bottles
at you and With You Know sketch comedy
whatever it's real safe with a bunch of
other people but you never did stand-up
comedy I know I did it a couple times in
a really really like amateurish Coffee
House [ __ ] was the goal always to be
on Saturday Night Live when you were a
little girl did you watch Saturday Night
Live and say that's my career yeah yeah
but I think a lot of people do it they
dream of being on Saturday Night Live
that was your thing yeah sure not to be
in the movies not to be to be on
Saturday Night Live yeah so how do you
get an audition to be on Saturday Night
Live even as a writer well they go to
Second City they go to this place the
Groundlings in LA or if you're a
stand-up and they audition people but I
never would have gotten in the regular
way like people they have to come they
do this audition and this this is the
you know the famous home-based stage
empty the whole place is empty you write
a packet of sketches and send it in
right how hard is that that's difficult
it is hard because now I've had to read
thousands of them because when I was a
head writer I had to hire people so you
dreamed as a little girl being on
Saturday Night Live and then you get
this writing opportunity and everyone
reads your stuff and they go wow you're
really really funny and then you start
working at Saturday Night Live and then
they make you the anchor woman yes boy
that's pretty [ __ ] good yeah I got
pretty lucky a few times and you were
good at it thank you I enjoyed watching
you do the news thank you did you write
most of the jokes for the news I wrote
Samba we had joke writers so I went in
the beginning I would sketches for
everybody else while the joke writers
wrote jokes for us she wrote two
sketches a week at least on Saturday
yeah wow what's the one you're most most
proud of
um I did a couple that were like one was
um this one with Christopher Walken and
Tim Meadows where um
Meadows was a census Taker and he was
talking to Christopher Walken and he was
like it's nuts you know and I did one
Rachel Dratch and I wrote one that we
really liked which was um it was a like
a show like Barney with the little kids
but she played a little girl who had
gone through puberty that was great
that's a really big and they were trying
to break it to her that her tits were
too big to be on the show anymore
up